do people who have acted horribly in
public life deserve a second chance
or does giving them a pass contribute to
a decline in morality and standards
that makes us all worse off i'm not
talking about the extreme cases like
movie mogul harvey weinstein who was
sentenced to 23 years in prison on rape
and assault convictions
and i'm not talking about people getting
cancelled because of random dumb tweets
online mobs or
years old statements ripped out of
context
i'm talking more about public figures
like lance armstrong
who was stripped of his record 7 tour de
france titles in 2012
after getting caught using banned
substances for basically his entire
professional career
and lying about it should we let him and
others like him back
into the public spotlight when they
don't really own their mistakes and try
to repair the damage they've done
to public trust and confidence overall
i think we're generally too quick to let
bygones be bygones i'm your host lance
armstrong i still do this podcast
armstrong is currently the face of we do
an events and media company and he hosts
a podcast
which covered the 2019 tour de france
and raked in an
estimated 1 million dollars in revenue
during the month-long event
here's a guy who doped insisted that he
hadn't doped
accused his competitors of doping he
took medals that did not belong to
him deny people for whom those medals
were intended
cultural anthropologist and brand
consultant grant mccracken has worked
with google netflix and kanye west
his new book is the new honor code a
simple plan for raising our standards
and restoring our good names mccracken
is a hard
no on giving folks like lance armstrong
a pass
it seems to me a guy who squandered his
own honor
and and brought dishonor upon the sport
ought not to be let back into the full
as we are openhearted americans we like
to think that oh people should be
forgiven people make mistakes there's
always a second act
in american culture i'm not sure there
should be a second half i think
once you've done something as bad as
that you're done you're out
honor the expectation that will hold
ourselves and others to high standards
has gone missing in our lives says
mccracken
too much of contemporary american
culture lets celebrities and public
figures
get away with what he calls monstrous
behavior partly because we view them as
entertainment and partly because we
project ourselves onto them
and don't want to judge ourselves too
harshly even some
armstrong critics argue that virtually
everyone in cycling used
performance-enhancing drugs
and some defenders of harvey weinstein
minimized his assault
by pointing to the long history of
hollywood's casting catch
lowering our standards and explaining
away bad behavior by claiming that
everyone breaks the rules in turn leads
to lower and lower standards for our own
personal behavior
in a system where everyone cheats and
gets away with misdeeds
mccracken says only a fool actually
plays by the rules
especially when no one is looking
mccracken is the farthest thing from a
moral scold
and he doesn't always call for the
figurative equivalent of the death
penalty for malefactors
but he says too often people don't pay
any price for bad behavior
as in the 2016 scandal involving the
harvard men's soccer team
who had created a spreadsheet ranking
the sexual desirability of
members of the women's team in graphic
detail
and violating the university's honor
code by lying about it when first
discovered
the players involved got away with
publishing an unsigned apology in the
student paper
and harvard's then president and dean of
students also let it all slide
these guys have to be pilloried or make
made an example of
but it seems to me when you look at the
details when you look at the damage done
by this behavior
there's a detailed account of of how one
young woman reacted psychologically it's
horrifying
and these guys are apparently um to
think that they regard themselves
as a above reproach
suggests that some larger point has to
be made here they have to understand
uh what they did and and the cost of
what they did
we'll always be adjudicating what we
consider bad behavior
and the appropriate social response on a
case-by-case basis
and mccracken is the first to admit that
there isn't a clearly objective measure
of whether we're less honorable than we
were
25 or 50 years ago but i think he's
fundamentally right that we tolerate a
huge amount of
absolutely rotten behavior that should
be called out for what it is
if our response to lying cheating and
acting despicably
is simply a collective shrug we can't be
surprised when we get
more of the same how can we restore
honor to our culture
mccracken says that a positive honor
culture one which expects individuals to
uphold standards of behavior
even when they conflict with personal
desire or gain
still exists in the military there's
still bad behavior there
but it's rarely excused on the grounds
that everyone does it
there is a code that governs your
behavior when you disappoint that code
you're much more culpable than you would
be if you were in civilian life
and misbehaved yourself and said well
everybody does it so it's okay for me
right
nobody in the military ever says well
everybody
goes awol this way or everybody steals
stuff where everybody
misuses their power so in fact i think
you get more good behavior and when
there is bad behavior that's more
culpable that's more punishable
mccracken believes that we must also do
more to recognize and celebrate the
people in our community
who do all sorts of things that make our
lives better
he writes about bob his neighbor in a
small town in connecticut
who has quietly helped build little
league fields helped out at local
hospitals as active in his church and
more so this guy does all this stuff
he's completely unheralded nobody in my
community has any clue
of what he does i said you know we need
more bars
as it turns out there are about five
bobs in my community i thought you know
if you created a reputation economy
and you found some way of giving people
credit for these accomplishments you
might be able to inspire
40 bobs to behave in this manner and all
boats would rise with that time
we live in an era where trust and
confidence in government business and
religious and charitable institutions
are at
or near historic lows and continue to
decline
the past year's experiences with
politics pandemics and riots
aren't going to turn that around anytime
soon while
endless and insane examples of cancel
culture
make it clear that none of us wants to
live in a world of one strike in your
out
we do well as a society to think
seriously about mccracken's call for a
new honor code
it's time to hold public figures and
ourselves
accountable for making the world a
better place